How effective is RIFE when a person is dealing with two different forms of cancer?
Well, it's just as effective, except it has to be programmed the right way.
Currently, I think I have at least to happen as the people have two completely different types of
cancer. No, that's pretty rare. So it's it's really kind of interesting that I have that
many people with that. So you could have two different types of breast cancer. That's that's
really easy because I don't program the right specifically to a type of breast cancer because I
have said this to every breast cancer patient that I personally, it's not that I don't trust
some pathologists with their eye that a microscope diagnoses the type of breast cancer.
It's just that I don't trust every pathologist behind that. It's easy, it still could be human error
and they could make a mistake in there. They could be off. So okay, we have eight hours every
night of programming. I'm putting in all the frequencies for every type of breast cancer.
So if you have two different types of breast cancer, it doesn't make any difference. You're getting
all the types of breast cancer in your program. If you had let's say if you had two different types
of brain cancer, we've had we've had people with a glioma, which is technically a brain tumor,
but it could be it's now graded and it could become an aggressive grade and be considered a cancer.
And they might have an astrocytoma so they can have a glioma and an astrocytoma. Actually,
they have a patient that has that. Well, then there's specific frequencies for astrocytoma and I put
that into that. I also put frequencies in for glioma so that that person is running those frequencies
every night for both those types of cancer. So is the right effective if you have two different types
of cancer? Yes, I also have couples like the husband as prostate cancer and the wife has breast cancer.
So they sleep in in the same bed in there and they can't afford to get two riffs. So we put both
their programs on the same right. And then we just time it the right way. So if they're communicating
with the couple, maybe the husband goes to bed earlier as he gets up early for work and the wife
was to bed a little later. So her programs are later in the evening if his programs are earlier in
the evening. So we just time it that way. So it's very easy to do. The right is only effective as
effective as the frequencies that you're running. So if you don't have it programmed directly to the
cancer, it's just not going to work. And remember, the right isn't this magic wand. It's going to cure
everybody. But it's going to be the most effective on killing pathogens. And it's going to be the
most effective on killing cancer. Again, with everybody's right machine, I program it with everything
you could think of. So it has frequencies in there for pain and frequencies in there for information
and such. And we have people that have given great testimonies that they work. But you know, that's
not really where the right shines perfectly. The right isn't the only tool that you would use for
things like that for sure. And a person the other day that tell me they didn't want to say it on
the zoom call, but they used the right for something other than cancer or pathogen, I think it was
for pain or anxiety or something. But she said it really didn't work. And she didn't want to say it
on the zoom call, because she didn't want me to feel bad. That make me feel bad. I know, I know, I know,
I don't have my faith in the right machine. I have my faith in God. And we have to use things wisely.
So just like I injured my knee again, because I have a partial tariff on to my mediscus that I
refused to go in and get surgery as I'm just stubborn old man. So I, you know, I injured it actually
about three years ago, playing soccer with the grandkids foolishly. And I used the right
on it and it really helped. But I also used PEMF. I also used laser. So you use other tools as well
as they're appropriate. So you're trying to heal anxiety. You're trying to heal a muscular
skeletal injury. Certainly you have the right. Use it. But it doesn't lead that you don't use other
tools. So, you know, I have a workshop in my bar and I have all sorts of tools, drills and saws
and hammers. And you use them where they're most appropriately geared for. So you just have to
understand that you could, you could get a screw in with a hammer. But it's a lot better to use
your screwdriver. And it is to use your hammer. So you, you want to try to use things appropriately.
But you're trying to deal with cancer. The right is the most effective tool as far as killing the
cancer by far compared to any other modality out there in my opinion. If you're trying to kill
pathogens like in the case of Lyme disease or chronic viral infections and things like that,
the right is the best tool. But let's say if I got a patient that comes to me and they say,
I don't have cancer. I don't have Lyme disease. I don't have any chronic infections. But I have this
toxicity. And I've had it tested and this is my whole issue is this toxicity. Should I buy a
rifle machine? Well, a rifle machine will help because it will help with the liver because it can
help the liver heal and help the liver function better. But really, you need to be doing some
different detox things. You need to follow my seven phase detox. You need to make sure you're
having moments. You need to be doing coffee and I'm assuming you need to be doing liver flushes.
There's lots of other things you need to do. So that's the idea of just using tools correctly.
All of them can be a benefit, but you use what's going to be best. I get lots of questions on case
reviews. I'm thinking I have cancer and I'm thinking of getting a hyperbaric chamber or I'm thinking to
get a rifle. What do you think I should get? Well, if you can afford to get both by all means,
I'm all in paper. If you have a tire therapy suite in your house, but what would I pick first?
Definitely, you're right. Well, then should I pick I can afford a hyperbaric? Should I get that
next? Well, it depends on what type of cancer you have. If you have brain cancer, well, then I don't
say maybe that would be next. If you have breast cancer, no, then maybe the next thing would be a
hyperthermia. So hyperthermia would be great for breast cancer or pancreatic cancer or liver cancer,
but not for brain cancer. So it depends on the type of cancer you have. What would be the next best tool
if you could afford it? Or if you could afford to go to a practitioner. Some practitioner has a
hyperbaric unit. So that's what he had here. She has. So he's hard selling them
buying a package of hyperbaric chamber. And this person has, you know, prostate cancer or liver cancer
or breast cancer. I'm sorry, it's not going to do a whole lot for that. If you had brain cancer,
then yes, go spend the sessions on there. But again, using tools properly and honestly,
is always the best thing I think for a practitioner. And for you as a patient to be educated in what
tools would be best. So don't ever feel mad about asking me out, be honest with you. I have all the
tools. I am a therapy junkie. But you know, it's just going to be honest, I guess. You don't
recommend things just because that's what you have to sell. And that's what you get a lot out there
on the internet these days is a lot of dishonesty in sales. So just beware.